bonjour merci d'être avec nous ce soir
sur arte france beaucoup de dossiers ont
été abordés par les deux dirigeants à
commencer par l'afghanistan où vladimir
poutine elle déclare qu'il faut empêcher
l'effondrement de l'afghanistan ne pas
permettre aux terroristes de quitter le
pays il appelle aussi à ne pas imposer
des valeurs étrangères alain ganis temps
comment se positionne le président russe
selon vous
eh bien je crois que il est dans la
logique de ce que la russie a soutenu
depuis quelque temps en particulier
depuis que des etats-unis ont engagé un
dialogue direct à doigts avec les
talibans
laissant supposer que
après le retrait pays il laissait aux
talibans la main libre sur le pays et la
russie a tout de suite établi ce que
l'on peut appeler à la fois un contact
avec les différentes parties qui pouvait
se partager le pouvoir en afghanistan
mais également avec tous les pays autour
de l'afghanistan pour essayer de dresser
une barrière contre l'infiltration de
l'idéologie talibane et des terroristes
en particulier au tadjikistan et en
ouzbékistan avec un dialogue très fort
avec ces pays et le renforcement des
troupes de frontières russes qui se
trouve actuellement au tadjikistan et
qui ont été renforcées dans le but
justement de bloquer la frontière mais
cela dit depuis 20 ans on voit que il
est impossible de trouver une solution
pour un développement pacifique peuvent
ganis temps et donc la russie 2 essayer
autre chose à en collaboration avec
d'autres pays de la zone c'est à dire
essayer de voir ce que les pallie les
talibans peuvent faire pour pacifier le
pays et dans quelle ne sûr on peut
s'entendre avec eux puisqu'il est
impossible de soutenir ce que l'on a
appelé le gouvernement démocratique qui
s'étaient effondrées en l'espace de
quelques jours kate en jeu aussi pour
moscou c'est la stabilité dans la région
c'est ce que les autorités mettent en
avant tout cas oui bien sûr c'est ce et
c'est ça le problème de la russie c'est
que elle est ouverte elle dit mais là
sur son territoire un nombre
impressionnant 25 millions de musulmans
qui ne sont pas du tout dans la logique
islamistes ce sont des gens qui se
comportent qui vivent leur religion
normalement et qui se comporte très bien
et qui sont totalement intégrés dans la
société
russe yens mais
il est toujours possible d infiltration
de laisser des infiltrations
de d'islamistes dans les pays d'asie
centrale qui peuvent contaminer de
proche en proche le sud de la russie
donc il est impératif non seulement pour
la russie d'un entendu mais également
pour les pays d'asie centrale de se
prémunir contre la déstabilisation qui
pourrait arriver d'afghanistan alors il
était aussi question cet après midi des
relations bilatérales entre la russie et
l'allemagne elles ont été mises à mal
par la faire un aval et angela merkel a
demandé la libération de l'opposant est
ce que vous vous voyez comment préalable
à tout réchauffement effectifs des
relations entre les deux pays
non non non ce n'est pas un préalable de
toute façon la russie ne cédera jamais
sûr navalni il est possible que d'ici
quelque temps on trouvera des
accommodements mais il doit purger sa
peine c'est inévitable si il se comporte
bien il peut avoir une mesure de de
grâce partielle ou d'aménagement de sa
détention
parce que pour la russie il s'agit non
pas d'une affaire politique mais d'une
affaire criminelle et c'est une affaire
criminelle qui
date de bien avant le fait que navalni
deviennent personnalité aussi le central
dans le jeu politique européen
il a été condamné à il ya plusieurs
années avec sursis il a violé les
conditions de son ceux ci est donc à
partir de là le sursis a été révoqué il
doit purger le restant de sa peine ça
c'est la position russe la position
européenne ces différentes on juge que
c'est un prétexte cette histoire de
sursis pour le faire taire maintenant
pour les russes navalni n'est pas
réellement un personnage central on le
présente ici comme l'opposant numéro un
mais en russie celle opposant tantièmes
il n'est pas il n'est pas considéré sauf
par les milieux disons branché dans les
grandes villes il n'est pas considéré
comme un personnage crédible est
d'ailleurs l'autre on écoute ce qu'il
dit
il y à un vide politique qui est assez
considérable son principal argument
c'est la lutte contre la corruption
contre la corruption en russie mais
maintenant il élargit le spectre à la
corruption dans tous les pays du monde
donc en fait il se positionne d'une
manière très particulière
et
je ne vois pas honnêtement que kylie est
un enjeu là dessus en revanche c'est le
dernier voyage
de dangla merkel en tant que chancelière
elle va quitter le pouvoir il va y avoir
un nouveau chancelier
vraisemblablement armin laschet tu si
les élections bien entendu lui donne la
possibilité d'accueil
d'arriver au pouvoir la position de la
chatte sur la rue si différente de celle
de merkel il est plus
russophiles disons il est plus axé sur
la reprise des relations
bien entendu il fera partie d'une
coalition est ce que la coalition lui
laissera la main libre on n'en sait pour
le moment rien on verra les élections
mais également en russie le 19 septembre
il y a également des élections et c'est
les premières élections législatives qui
vont se dérouler dans la perspective
enfin sous la nouvelle mouture de la
constitution et vraisemblablement il y
ait d'aia voir un changement
d'orientation
avec l'arrivée d'un nouveau premier
ministre enfin on ne sait pas trop
comment d'un côté et de l'autre les
choses vont se passer mais donc ce
sommet d'aujourd'hui n'est que la
dernière partie d'un jeu qui a commencé
il ya très longtemps qui s'est ternie au
moment de la sphère ukrainienne en 2014
et qui maintenant arrive à sa fin il va
y avoir autre chose quoi on n'en sait
strictement rien mais en tout cas le
dialogue avec la russie est établi les
présidents le président macro et la
chancelière merkel avait demandé à
l'union européenne d'engager le dialogue
avec la russie en mai dernier
l'union européenne n'a pas voulu pour
parce que il y à de très nombreux
intérêts antirusse dans de nombreux pays
européens de l'est de l'europe en
particulier et donc
les choses en sont là mais le dialogue
bilatéral aussi bien entre l'allemagne
et la russie contre la france et la
russie va se poursuivre va continuer et
puis on verra bien comment les choses
évoluent il y à un point positif très
positif dans le dialogue entre
l'allemagne et la russie c'est que la
chancelière merkel et le président
américain joe biden sont parvenus à un
accord sur le gazoduc north stream
et ça c'est pour aussi bien pour
l'allemagne que pour la russie une
bouffée d'oxygène dans leur relation
parce qu'effectivement la russie a
besoin de vendre son gaz et l'allemagne
a2 - du gaz russe pour se séparer un peu
de sa dépendance au charbon et à la
limite qui sont très polluants comme on
le sait par conséquent la s'éteint c'est
un jeu gagnant gagnant qui peut de
proche en proche un show nourrir un
dialogue beaucoup plus détendu merci
beaucoup pour votre analyse pierre
laurent journaliste spécialiste de la
russie